ronnie jackson my doctor  doc ron where's ron  where's ron  he was the white house doctor he was a  great doctor you know he was a admiral a  doctor and now he's a congressman i said  which is the best if you had your choice  and he sort of indicated doctor because  he loved looking at my body it was so  strong powerful  but he said i'm the healthiest president  that's ever lived  i was the healthiest i said i like this  guy i don't know who the hell he is at  the time i said but  so yeah i mean this entire healthiest  president thing it's so stupid first  because ronnie jackson didn't examine  every president like you know it's  totally conceivable that uh teddy  roosevelt was healthier than trump but  also trump is very clearly not healthier  than the person he  followed barack obama so it's just very  very strange stuff